il est en france
cent mille enfants comme celle-ci
séparés de leurs parents pour les
raisons qu'ils ne comprennent pas qu'ils
ne connaissent pas trimbaler
trimbalé depuis toujours de château en
château de foyer en foyer de séparation
en séparation
que devient l'amour d'un enfant pour ses
parents lorsqu'il est sans objet en
amour n'est jamais sans être un jouet
une photographie peuvent faire la faire
c'est arrivé quand ici quand tu arrives
et caen dimanche
tu viens d'où temir porras
j'étais chez des gens oui depuis
l'antiquité
ça devait faire deux ans et demi et
avant avant j'étais dans un château où
je manque le plus
et avant château j'étais encore dans un
lot tu te rappelles plus les noms si
j'étais amorçant puis havre new york à
l'âge de 14 ans je contente
rires mais moi oui et asnières tout
plein
oui beaucoup jeter dans une famille avec
des enfants
oui tulle en classe oui tu regrettes
asnières oui
qu'est ce que tu vas faire
pourquoi ont été retirés daniel tc oui
parce que ferais je travaille qu'une
travail au parlement
si mais il faut que j'appelle un métier
qu'est ce que tu veux faire je voudrais
faire courir ici tu vas pouvoir le faire
je crois oui mais ces gens donnent fière
viens de te voir
oui tu l'avais écrit oui
tu vas tu habitués ici oui ça me fait
toujours
ça me fait que des gens qu il commet
cette dernière
explique moi qu'est-ce que tu regrettes
donne
ce que je voulais rester avec ma
nourrice
[Musique]
et tu n'étais là que depuis l'âge de 12
ans ce manoury ce oui je crois que c'est
la personne que tu aimes le plus 7 ans
oui tout gentil
si tu cherches bien comme ça qu'elles
sont des premiers souvenirs tension
ils mois
tu ne veux pas je sais pas
de quoi tu te souviens choses comme ça
que tu aurais vu les bonnes choses que
tu aurais vu quand j'allais me promener
le dimanche en voiture avec qui avec ma
nourrice mais d'avant quand j'étais tout
petit quand j'allais en promenade
à quel âge à 9 ans je ne te parle de la
période où tu étais vraiment toute
petite fille parce que tu as des
souvenirs et aucun souvenir
tu étais heureuse asnières oui
tu seras encore
pourquoi sont-ils là les raisons sont
nombreuses sont classés misère morale
misère matérielle misère affective
d'audi alcoolisme accidents par an
dénaturer mort des parents l'enfant lui
n'entre jamais dans ses raisons
quelle honte ans que tu laisses et non
depuis dimanche
ah bon je viens d'arriver
c'est difficile un petit peu du
collégien oui les deux premiers jours où
est attendu au début on me dit que oui
parce que j'étais avec mes chers tel
oubli c'est pas pareil ici autrement ça
va c'est courageux et bien
et avant que tu étais un milieu bretagne
ou au dessert
dans un foyer jeunes aux riches
que rester longtemps que cette touriste
je peux seulement sept mois tu vas voir
quelques fois j'y vais toujours me
couche
tu t'ennuies d'elle
on peut l entente de trois ans et avant
avant j'étais chez une nourrice et quel
endroit
goussainville et à 20 avant j'étais à
versailles à versailles on sur des
réservoirs d'eau qu'ils viennent ans et
les oiseaux ils passent tous par ici le
foyer départemental de versailles
le service de la rue des réservoirs à
décider de leur sort
pour beaucoup d'entre eux la rue devrait
revoir c'est le commencement de tout
enfant abandonné à la naissance au plus
tard
enfin oublier
marcellin
enfant séparé la suite de retrait
obligatoire ou demandées par les parents
ou même quelquefois c'est arrivé par
l'enfant lui même
[Musique]
en seine et oise seulement cinquante
mille cas d'enfants en danger signalé en
un an
dix mille retirés de leur famille
[Musique]
c'est ici aussi qu'on abandonne les
nouveau nés
quelques heures après la sortie de la
maison d'accouchement vers six heures du
soir
quelquefois dans la nuit ceux là seront
les plus heureux seront adoptées pour
les autres c'est ici que se passera
l'enfance
maintenant qu'est-ce qui te montre la
bande à blanc jean n'a pas trouvé et toi
festival c'est fini voilà mon travail
est presque terminée c'est bien donc
c'est peut-être pas tout à fait net
je crois que tu dois avoir d'autres lem
dans ton sac regardes tu vois tu me
détends qui sont entrés aux truffes
arabe tu dois avoir certainement dépend
beaucoup plus chaud mais les laisser à
côté des autres
henry a sept frères et soeurs il ne
s'est pas tous séparés et parents
n'étaient pas méchants mais incapable
d'élever leurs enfants le père et ma
mère devient plus depuis cinq ans on ne
sait pas pourquoi cela
qu'est ce que tu faisais en place
jusqu'à faire
on n'a pas jour
en paille au raphia
tu veux devenir caméraman
[Musique]
tu sais commande le bien commun prenant
bien mort
fiction plane plus fort on apprend en
apprenant bien les chanteurs nous donne
dis moi quelle bande la journée que tu
peux faire du matin au soir comme ça
l'après midi
le matin pourquoi je suis même idée chez
palm pilot matin et tu vas voir beaucoup
de temps comme ça oui
qu'est ce que tu fais de temps en temps
les camarades à quoi
voilà que la collerette aux gendarmes et
aux voleurs des grands shows quand tu
lui délivre quelques fois oui quand on
lit le soir à la veillée
mais tu parles jamais ici avec qui tu
parles avec mes camarades mais avec des
grands prix qui défient j'étais gamin
oui moi aussi donc sinon je suis une
voiture qui vient faire
qu'est ce que tu as vu je veux chantre
de la terre quoi je retrouve de la terre
parce que ça lui parle de la drac ou
d'un homme
et puis ce que veut encore le fils du
capitaine blood
tu avais joué ici jouent plutôt était
trop grand j'ai déjà les gens courent
à quoi je me suis tapé chez bourjois dit
qu'est ce que tu pourrais faire à tous
ces deux revers un péché pêcher dans les
temps oui qu'est ce qu'il ya dans le
temps y'a des brochets ya des branchés
sur wii y a des il ya des tanches et des
gauchos et vous pouvez les faire cuire
ici vous pouvez manger le prix qu'est-ce
que ça devient quand tu les ingrats on
veut enlever relâche car combien leur
chair de deux frères picture tells est
connu
tu connais qu'une seule des grandes et
dans un centre d'apprentissage
il est avec toi avant si taxi qui la
voyaient ville dimanche y'a pas de
bateau il aurait pu mettre un petit
canot il avait avant lui trouver un nom
ces grands pas et des animaux ici mais
des chats des chiens ou ya un chien
avant je n'ai pas vu un tout petit mais
des animaux sauvages tourne à vue oui il
ya un carrier de lapin ou l'un d'eux
près de l'étang non tout près la
japonaise des oiseaux il y en ad autres
oui il ya des pigeons des dirigeants ils
viennent jusqu'à près de la maison
la fusion yvonne est en faillite il a
traversé les plates bandes
tu connais pas paris quelle ville du
cannet versailles pontoise le lapin ils
viennent jusque là sur la terrasse vous
lapins ils viennent jusque sur le
terrain sortie changements dans les bois
ils sont habitués aux enfants mais tous
vous en trouvez des animaux les oiseaux
oui quelle merde tout petit oui qu'est
ce que tu fais là où les noués par le
relâche
ah oui j'ai pas vu de cash dans la
maison que nous y fabriquons son parti
pour les franges
oui des poissons si tu en prends et on a
été acheminé au prix ici là sur les
temps qu'est ce tu fais le dimanche
richard hein je vais demander la chute
en état de péché
ils ne disent pas mes parents ne
viennent jamais ils disent mes parents
viennent rarement
c'est une façon d'avoir quand même les
parents
parfois des parents se souviennent de
l'existence de leurs enfants lorsque
ceux ci atteignent l'âge de 12 ans l'âge
de se rendre utile ils sont soignés ici
comme jamais ils n'ont été mais ce n'est
pas suffisant c'est le jamais ses fils
mme la mer et le premier lien qui
s'établit entre l'enfant et le monde
extérieur
l'amour de la mer est par définition un
amour sans limites dès la naissance
la qualité les ce lien conditionne le
devenir d'un enfant qu'il existe ou non
un enfant a besoin d' intérêt du modèle
du père y modèle de la mère d'amour il a
besoin d'être aimé en tant que tel il a
besoin d'être préféré à tous qu'est ce
que tu as connu des parents
ils sont venus une fois chez moi pour
vous pour vous re venir me chercher je
les ai ma nourrice m'a demandé mon avis
j'ai entendu non quand ils sont venus
j'ai eu peur qu'ils me reprenne
puis vous avez jamais vus non une seule
fois c'est tout cas combien de temps tu
avais que l'âge quand ils sont mieux
13h30 tu avais peur qu il reprenne
oh oui comme j'ai pas voulu elle
rassemble pas assisté à quel âge tu as
été mises en use and an et demi tu es
grand maintenant on t'a dit pourquoi pas
oui on va pas encore tout dit mais enfin
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il paraît que
mes parents me battais puis alors on m'a
retiré
tu as deux soeurs
oui deux soeurs okala jeu plus petit que
toi wyss 13 ans et demi et 14 ans elles
ont également été retirés
oui qu'est ce que tu feras plus tard je
vais couturière est marié et toi
tu veux des enfants
lee oui beaucoup beaucoup alors deux la
caractéristique d'un enfant ce ne ne pas
pouvoir exprimer ce qu'il ressent mais
d'agir ce qu'il ressent il faut lui
apprendre à répondre à traduire son
sentiment à quel âge pour ceux ci
commencera le dialogue devient
légèrement et que tu es chez pierre se
joindront
j'avais un centre de petites filles
c'est tout petit quand j'étais tels que
la logique pour lui avant ça
j'étais chez mon frère
et avant cou
tu ne sais rien
tu travailles très bien
mais ça va et toi tu vas passer son
certificat d'études
une poupée qu'est-ce que tu tricote
brassière ça tu peux cesser
on les a frappés 11h03 joue avec nom et
après tu fais pas de la gare
oui mais d'une manière pas
cela fait de ton frère qui tapait qu'il
fait et bientôt oui souvent
le troisième dimanche chez moi
paris
il ya noël une dernière vous avez une
autre amant mais je veux ni un voyou
[Musique]
est-ce que tu aime le plus au monde
et au ballon
[Musique]
et les personnes qu'ils occasionnent que
plus solide
[Musique]
ils seraient 1
tu sais où aller
je n'ai pu
elle est morte
[Musique]
le groupe est considéré comme le
substitut de l'univers parental très
souvent le jeune qui rejoint un groupe
attend de celui-ci ce qu'il n'a pas
trouvé chez lui la violence est
affirmations de l'enfant désir de
prendre sa place dans le monde et les
revendications affirmations et défense
elle peut être la base de la scolarité
travail et même de l'art les violences
ne peut pas être séparé de l'amour quand
il n'y a pas d'amour dont il faille se
séparer les raisons de la lutte pour la
vie ne sont pas aperçus ne sont pas
ressenti la violence ne se canalise pas
elle rejoint la violence tout court
[Musique]
est ce que tu veux faire plus tard je
voudrais m'engager dans la marine ah bon
j'aime beaucoup les bateaux oh oui
quelle est la mère de gens ont envie tu
nages
oui il faut travailler beaucoup du cese
une
qu'est-ce que tu aime aussi le football
je suis sûr tu as l'air d'un petit
footballeur comme ça ne joue pas au foot
- un peu quitte amesys ont eu oui
tu as des joues oui puisque tu là on a
déjà bien construire on a des ballons
tout ce qu'il nous faut qu'est ce tu
vois toi
mon pied
ok
pourquoi pompiers
comme la flotte non alors
villa mois explique moi
non
et comme un tank et s'est fait un nom
tu t'es wavre ont été réduits chez un
homme
oui j'étais toujours resté avec cette
dame là s'appelle comment donc je n'ai
pas connu
n'allons pas discuter je ne sais pas le
nom de cet homme chez qui tu es et tu
arrives à quel âge c'est cette table
j'avais arrivé à 5 ans et avant
outré terme
c'est à venir lit je m'amuse j'étais à
versailles dans une famille non foyer
elle bientôt voir sa nourrice non c'est
pas que je suis si tu voudrais que le
sache
oui elle peut être te reconnaître comme
ça à la télévision
vous avez joué le phoque et oui qu'est
ce que vous en faites au gel évoqué
l'état c'est dire eh oui il est un homme
très attachant il est très fantasque
enfin moi je laime bien il m'a fait voir
ils ont fait énormément voir enfin
jeunes aiment bien quand joël foucades
et que qui ne connaît ni le nom les
adresses de sa nourrice ce n'est pas
vrai oh non il le sait il le sait pas ce
qu'il a sur une petite carte à lui
donner à noël et pourquoi le ridicule ce
plan son petit secret c'est peut-être ce
qu'il y a ceux qui lui a écrit déjà deux
ou trois fois mais lui a jamais répondu
et moselle si vous aviez votre mot à
dire dans tout ça qu'elle se lâche aux
réformes et d'imprévus qu une monitrice
soit pour 5
qu'est ce que beaucoup plus de 2,2 d'un
petit groupe que des 10 qui donne
d'autant plus de monitrice qu d'enfants
n'y a pas ces brigands je trouve
oui lorsque vous êtes pour confère
qu'est-ce que quelque chose de mieux
disent vous êtes perdus on est parent
non n'est pas perdue jeu des camarades
du canon 16 les grandes filles elles
sont seize dans l'est dans les équipes
enfin je trouve que pour surtout pour
des petits il vaudrait mieux être une
monitrice pour 5
parce que par exemple pour joël fouquet
je devrais être spécialement que pour
lui alors que je n'ai naf derrière
comprenez je ne peux pas aller par
exemple le voir chercher joël faut que
je le fous qu'elle s'en va à la pêche
faudrait on a toujours peur qu'ils
tombent à l'eau faudrait que j'aille le
voir il les eaux les nouveaux d'autres
tout seul pour mieux que je sois allé le
vôtre que derrière jal fouquet
il ne parle jamais des origines à 6 en
parle mais de temps en temps quand le
moment se présente à vous oui et vous
demande des explications
alain parce que la plupart d'entre eux
ne savent pas pourquoi ils sont là ils
commencent à leur est arrivé ne le
savent pas on leur a dit fallait leurs
parents leur papa leur maman leur ont
dit certaines choses ma faim et beaucoup
d'orphelins
il y en a qui ne pense pas parce qu'ils
ont des nourrissons n'ont jamais vu
leurs parents mais c'est qu'ils ont
quand même un parent et s'y attachent
il en reparle il est dans les consignes
de ne pas leur en parler à nous on n'est
pas tellement au courant de ce qui s'est
passé chez eux
longtemps
safir 2 mois de ventes j'étais un énième
jeu des gens car les chieuses le monde
j'étais chez mes parents
voilà je fais partie
j'avais deux ans
je les vois quelquefois ils viennent
tous les jeux telle visite
oui si sérail du frère dont sont issus
non il y en a deux qui sont chez ma
marraine glissé j'en ai trois qui sont
signés chez les religieuses et que mes
parents gars qu'est ce qui s'est passé
une bonne place là il n'y avait pas de
place d'apple jacqueline le jeune joe
cada dont je suis la télévision venue
mais que voulez vous dire quelque chose
je me trouvais par an
au tour des parents de contenir ce que
tu as su faire depuis l'âge de 5 ans
parfois j'utilise assistance commenter
les a perdus
weight en place a été placé dans une
maison
oui dans quelles circonstances est
arrivé de les a perdus et comment ils
sont morts
non je les ai quittés
un contre moi
je vivais à mon père moment donné avec
mon père ou dans un bâtiment je croise à
paris et tout vient pdt tout petit bébé
avec ton père dans le bâtiment à paris
oui la même pièce ensemble en territoire
quant à mr souvient quaden le débat jeu
alors on se retrouve à l'hôpital tous
les deux oui oui des malades
c'est en décembre oui noël tous les
jours j'allais voir gtc bon boulot tous
les jaunes puis soir tu étais dans un
voiture peut-être gens même au plus tard
mi juillet et puis
moi je vais à trouver moi je suis à vue
au coach a besoin de mémoire et c'est
bien ce qui s'est passé
tu allais voir ton père matin oui il est
pas de même des friandises
peu après j'ai eu ma place je pense ici
tu m'a placé dans une maison je prenais
le ruis du matin il ne l'est pas je peux
enfin j'ai pu revue justement
je peux jouer sa vie qui je veux prouver
qu'avec d'auteur en france depuis
plusieurs judokas du nombre non
quand j'étais petit je me souviens
jouait dans dans mon jardin
j'avais une voiture à pédales que mon
coeur s'est assise sur le mot soit de
voir des voitures bus me disais avis
final j'avais répondu à mon père je veux
que je pouvais pas lui qui est trop
lourd et de voir la maison il y avait
des personnes via la banque et un enfant
dans les bras et c'était j'ai supposé
c'était un deuil qu'il faut un petit
serge tandis que tu voulais avoir mal
est retrouvé six jeudi sur des fruits
oui tout le monde perd jamais une
jacqueline le jeune tu fais je n'ai à
paris de paris dans le 10ème
arrondissement dans le 10e
arrondissement et tu voudrais vous
pouvez sinon on perd moins si tu en as
tes frères et soeurs la séparation
d'avec les parents et sans doute la plus
grave perturbation de la première
enfance séparation ici successives des
vrais parents d'abord puis ensuite de la
mère nourricière et ensuite encore des
différents foyers est extrêmement grave
elle se lie profondément dans l'enfant
il nous a paru que c'était là le seul
point sur lequel il faudrait peut-être
revenir dans l'organisation par ailleurs
tout à fait remarquable de la protection
de l'enfance en danger
[Musique]
un enfant m'a dit qu'il ne voulait plus
partir d'ici parce qu'il aimait le parc
ce parc
oui
[Musique]
l'enfant sans foyer
sa possibilité d'amour diminuent ils se
protègent de la déception
son intérêt pour le monde extérieur
diminue aussi il se ferme
il offre le moins de prise possible au
coup du sort il offre très souvent les
apparences de la débilité alors qu'il
est intelligent il a peur de quoi
de l'avenir
[Musique]